yo what is up everybody this procedure
man Luigi here with another Borderlands
the pre-sequel legendary guide in this
video I'm going to be showing you how to
get the 3d d1 dot e Hyperion legendary
ah skits this Alex Kidd will give you an
explosive slam boost plus a variety of
other perks and benefits it has a pretty
good odds capacity it always increases
your shield capacity increases your
laser damage increases your air control
well maybe not increases but I have
never seen another Alex kid with better
air control and gives you pretty good
smack slam damage now I say it always
has this because I have come across all
the 3d one keys that I've come across
which have been to have had the exact
same stats at being level at the net
level of 50 now what makes this unique
is that also you can see you can read
the description there it is a pretty
long description um it will randomly
recharge your shields in battle and
electrocute enemies that melee you so
say your da u is so the boss got your
shields down and got your health then
you're about to go down there's no one
in sight that you're gonna get a revive
off you're like oh I've got this boss
that sounds so low I don't want to die
here this 3d d1e might revive your
shields full in the middle of taking
damage so that's probably my favorite
aspect about this I do really like the
air control and the laser damage is a
pretty great thing but the ability to
just recharge your shield at any point
is just something that's pretty
spectacular in my mind so I'm gonna be
showing you how to get it and kind of
throughout the gameplay I'll be have one
on so you can you can see for yourself
kind of what it's like
alright so to get this ask a you're
going to have to do the emission
eradicate now this is a mission you can
find on Jack's board in Jack's office
and you're gonna have to do a one or two
missions I think for chairman Tassadar
before you're allowed this mission so
when to get this mission you're gonna
head into the veins of Helios and you
make a long run so I'm gonna have a
slowed down version of this if you want
to see you're gonna have to get three
parts I'm going to show you where to get
all these three parts if the map does
tell you where to get them they're too
hard to find but if you want to see a
slower slowed down version of this then
just go to the end of the video and I'll
have a slower version where you can
see where to get all this stuff in a
little more detail so once you pick up
these three things you're gonna go
construct them in the main room and then
you're going to get a little claptrap
slash Dalek unit now if you don't know
what the Dalek is it's from the show
Doctor Who I've never actually seen the
show but there's a ton of the social
media references I see to it practically
every day so I have a general gist idea
of what the show is like so you're gonna
get you're gonna see this is where I am
constructing all the materials and
eventually you're gonna get a little
robot that pops out and he is going to
shoot electric charges at and any enemy
he sees now you are considered an enemy
and these electric charges are very
powerful and you can get down and get
killed from them so be careful hide
behind stuff when you're leading so
you're gonna have to lead him to kill
egg hood the engineer you get bonus
money if you let him kill egg hood
however I think you can your art you are
able to do this mission and get the 3d
d1e regardless so you can see there's
egghead I got them down pretty far since
if you just let the Dalek unit kill and
it's gonna take a long time so once you
kill egg head the claptrap unit is gonna
go rogue and you it can either secure it
in the room or destroy it now if you
want the 3d one you're gonna have to
destroy it and I believe you can save
and quit to do this you once you're here
you can just go save and quit and come
back and he'll still be here however I
had I have heard a lot about having to
alt f4 to do this where it's you quit
the game you come back so the first time
I alt F forward and you see I after two
tries on my second try at all f4 once I
second try I got the legendary now I do
not know what can save and quit if it's
confirmed with my games laggy so I would
suggest a saving I would suggest f4 and
doing it now there's also legendary that
you can pull off on egghead and he
continuously spawns after you kill them
once after so after the mission you can
i'm almost nine a 99% sure that you'll
be able to kill I could completely
afterwards it'll be completely fine and
you'll need all of for the claptrap unit
I do not know so be on the safe side
you're going to
on f4 alt f4 and that's basically how
you get the 3G z1e you might have
noticed any times in that video of
anyone beat me or my shields got low
sometimes it recharged or shocked and so
that's basically it this is the video
I'm gonna let this rest of this gameplay
play out this is what I said I'm going
to show you the three places where you
can get all the things a little bit
slower
it is not normal pace and that would
take way too long it is a double speed
but I think you should still be able to
get where find out where the stuff is so
guys I have been I thank you for
watching the video up to now I
appreciate any support and get a look at
something going to continue to do more
legendary guides I have already a few
legendary guides up so make sure you
check those out and I thank you for
watching the video peace out guys